we examine the brand-new economic report
Democrats say Americans are the problem
so vote Democrat and president from
Clinton's do his story about hurricane
Dorian and plays with sharpies I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
right it was a lot to get to today there
is a new study out about the collapse of
marriage and it suggests that economics
has something to do with that I think
economics does have something to do with
it but I think the problem goes a lot
deeper we'll get to that a little bit
later on in the show we will also be
getting to president Trump's bizarre
fixation with how correct he was about
the storm path of the storm that didn't
go anywhere remotely near where he said
it was good who cares why are we still
on this because the president doesn't
let those sorts of things go well get
all that in just one second first we
begin with the August at jobs report so
according to the New York Times the
United States added 130,000 jobs in
August the unemployment rate remains at
three point seven percent meaning that
the economy remains strong the figures
show that the economy continues to add
jobs despite the trade war and a global
showdown
what we are seeing is a trend line that
looks like it is headed down since the
beginning of 2019 in terms of job growth
had a couple of very bad months we had
February which is a very bad month and
then we had a couple of months later it
looks like May was a very bad month
we've had some okay months mixed in but
overall it looks as though the economy
is slowing now it doesn't mean recession
is around the corner it does mean that
the economy is going to be slower it
looks like headed into 2020 which of
course is not great news for president
Trump according to the New York Times
the American economy turned in a decent
performance last month as businesses
grew more cautious about hiring
according to the Labor Department's
monthly employment report released on
Friday about 25,000 of the jobs added
were temporary position for the 2020
census when you remove those jobs and
the job growth looks even slower now
does this mean we are in economic spiral
that doom is upon us no it means that a
lot of people have a lot of trepidation
about the future of the economy and
they're not doing a lot of long-term
hiring right now in the expectation that
sometime in 2020 2021 we may see an
economic downturn and that's not a
surprise because we've been seeing those
indicators systemically coming from
China coming from Europe for several
months at this point along with consumer
spending the labor market has been a
source of stability for the economy even
as several gauges have turned downward
and trade anxieties
mounted but in August the private sector
added 96 thousand jobs weaker than the
pace so far in 2019 and an indication
that businesses are becoming a little
more reluctant to add headcount
the report also revised down job gains
for June and July by a total of 20,000
which you know going back and having to
revise down numbers is never great
polish worth is the chief US economist
at capital like economics he said the
headline number in August was flattered
by the big increase in census hiring he
says even allowing for that there's been
a clear slowdown in trend employment
growth with the three-month and
six-month averages both at around
150,000 now down from about 230,000 a
year ago but there were positive signs
elsewhere in the report the labor force
participation rate did rise to sixty
three point two percent from 63 percent
suggesting that workers who had been on
the sidelines are gradually being lured
back into the labor market and average
hourly earnings did increase by 0.4
percent which is actually more than
analysts had expected which suggests
again when you have wage increases that
suggests that the demand for labor is
exceeding the supply for labor by 0.4
percent in terms of wages the length of
the average work week also increased
after falling in July so it there
there's some mixed numbers right now it
looks like the economy is sort of on the
brink of something right it could be on
the brink of another slow growth cycle
it could be on the brink of a slowdown
turn it could be on the brink of a
recession over the course of the next
couple years businesses don't know and
so they're holding back their money a
good piece of news for President Trump
may be that that economic report is not
bad for Trump it's it's it's okay for
Trump it's just not spectacular for
Trump a good piece of news for president
Trump's that the markets were up pretty
significantly yesterday according to the
New York Times president Trump's
decisions were new talks with China in
the coming weeks sent financial markets
soaring on Thursday as investors seized
on the development as a sign that both
sides could still find a way out of an
economically damaging trade war the
rally sent the S&P 500 up more than 1%
underscoring just how much financial
markets are subsisting on hopes and
fears about the trade war shares fell
through most of August as mr. Trump
escalated his fight with China and
imposed more tariffs only to snap back
on Thursday after news of the talks but
expectations for progress remain low
many in the US and China see the best
outcome as a continued stalemate that
would prevent a collapse in relations
before the 2020 election and that is
probably the most likely outcome because
the fact is that the United
it's not gonna kind of long-term trade
deal with China not under the current
conditions in which China is a serious
geopolitical enemy of the United States
and characterizing China this way is not
a partisan affair
hey the left in the United States is
similarly beginning to recognize the
China is a geopolitical threat to the
United States and that harsh action is
neck necessary Nicholas Kristof was a
very left-leaning columnist for The New
York Times has a piece today talking
about how China is is ramping up its
military presence around Taiwan about
how they've escalated their cyberattacks
on Taiwan about how China's becoming
more militant I mean he he even
acknowledges that President Trump's
policies on Taiwan are better than his
predecessors I mean this is Nicholas
Kristof was no friend of Trump he says
President Trump has generally been more
supportive of Taiwan than his
predecessors and that's worked well so
far but this has to be done very
carefully but he points out Beijing has
been really attacking Taiwan's
capabilities that China has been
stepping up its military pressure by
increasing patrols in the area that they
could hold military exercise in the area
Taiwan's foreign minister Joseph Wu said
quote we are very concerned
he said one concern was that a slowing
economy and other troubles in China
might lead xi to make trouble for Taiwan
as a distraction this is the scenario
that is constantly playing on the minds
of the key decision-makers on Taiwan he
said so what that means that the most
likely outcome is indeed some sort of
stalemate in terms of the United States
and China that allows for continued
economic growth up through the 2020
election although it won't be booming in
the same way that it would be if we
weren't in the middle of a trade war
with one of our largest trading partners
and again I think there are very good
reasons to get into a trade war with
China based on China's aggression on 5g
based on their aggression in terms of
their belt and road projects based on
their aggression in terms of naval
presence in the South China Sea and
their aggression in Hong Kong and their
aggression against Taiwan no those are
all good reasons for us to take a very
skeptical view of relations with China
overall we just have to acknowledge that
that will dampen growth a little bit
going more than a little bit probably
going into 2020 now in just a second
we're gonna talk about the vulnerability
for Democrats because right now would
seem like a pretty good time for
Democrats where President Trump is not
popular in terms of his overall approval
rating the Democratic Party is seeing
significant gains in the polls in states
Wisconsin and states like Texas wouldn't
this be a great time for the Democratic
Party well they've got one problem and
that's they can't get out of their own
way we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about improving the
employees of your company so let's be
frank I could get here on time more
often for my podcast right we've been
starting a little bit late for this
podcast nearly every day and there a
variety of excuses I could make to you
but the truth is that if I were the most
rigid kind of boss I would fire me and
replace me but let's be honest I'm not
replaceable so but if I were I would be
looking to zipper critter to replace me
I mean I can promise you we didn't find
Michael moles to reciprocate like I'd be
looking for an actual good host to
replace me via zip recruiter com go
check out zip recruit comm slash daily
wear zip recruiter will send your job
posting to over 100 of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there as
the applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each and every one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match a zipper
critter is so effective that four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
can a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter dot-com / Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire and so if ever I decide that I can
no longer be trusted to even do the
podcast let alone get here on time I
will be looking to zip recruiter for my
own replacement zip recorder calm slash
daily wire we always enjoy our zip
recruiter ads because somebody has to
draw the short straw in terms of who is
going to get nailed by the zipper career
ad today plus I so zip recruited Zack
huh the slash daily wire if you wish to
upgrade your employees okay so why is it
that the polls are not better for
Democrats in terms of favorability and
there's that there's a shocking new
YouGov poll economists you got poll
taken between September 1st and 3rd and
it's kind of fascinating because what it
shows is that both Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders actually have a lower
favorability ratings than President
Trump in the new YouGov poll Biden's
favorable and unfavorable Zinn his poll
are 42 percent favorable 51 percent
unfavorable for a net 9 negative 9
Bernie's are 42 and 50 for a net
negative 8 Trump's are 46 and 52 for a
net negative 7 this is that
bizarre I mean that is a bizarre result
so why are Democrats not more popular
why are Democrats now more probably like
Trump makes himself quite vulnerable as
we will see president Trump has a habit
of stepping on his own you know but you
know the fact is that the Democrats are
not making themselves popular well one
reason they're not making themselves
popular is their pitch seems to be
something like this
Americans you suck you're terrible
right there are certain groups of
Americans that are probably okay they've
been historically victimized and but but
all the rest of you you suck and even
the ones who are members of groups that
are historically victimized let's be
real about this it kind of stuck also
because after all you are consuming the
world's resources after all your
believers in cruel horrible religion
after all your your people who are
hypocrites in terrible the the new
Puritans all are in the Democratic Party
it really is an impressive thing and
I've been knocked before for being
quote-unquote a religious fundamentalist
which is always kind of hilarious to me
considering I wrote an entire book about
the necessary and then the necessity for
balance between religion and faith and
how they support each other and buttress
each other rather than splitting
everything apart but the the case that
fundamentalism wise on the right is
belied by the religious fundamentalism
of the left about politics the way that
the Democrats talk about politics these
days it's sinners in the hands of an
angry god I mean we have full Jonathan
Edwards talk about modern American
politics you Americans have sinned and
you must atone and this is how you end
up with a 7-hour of climate change Town
Hall in which the Democrats claim that
like religious figures of old they're
going to ban all the things they're
going to set up their own set of
Commandments and they're going to ban
all the things here are Democrats just
two nights ago talking about how all the
things will be banned all of them talk
about offshore drilling for oil would
you ban it yes we will transition off of
fossil fuels natural gas coal oil what
about the export of fossil fuels from
the United States of Japan that
absolutely we must get to that point
there's no question I'm in favor of
banning fracking I'm in favor of a
carbon-free America in my administration
we're not going to build any new nuclear
power plants we
we should set out the rules for what
kind of plant you know coal-burning
plants no one's going to build another
coal burning we've got to shut the ones
down we have we're gonna in factory
farming because that is not only that is
a danger to the environment and to
climate change we're gonna ban all the
things all the things that must be done
but they go further than this right the
most fundamentalist Democrat in the race
and this is a big shock to me it really
is because you didn't start off his
candidacy this way
the angriest dude on the Democratic side
of the aisle the woke scold of woke
scold is actually people who to judge so
peabody judge started off this race and
he was a much more interesting candidate
he was this sort of interesting purple
state governor he's in indiana he's
trying to reach across the aisle to
republicans he says he'll eat it
chick-fil-a he's he knows a lot about
issues he can talk really well he didn't
seem like the kind of guy who was going
to go full on I'm gonna lecture you like
an angry school marm and it seemed more
like an Elizabeth Warren candidacy and
Warren has that but Buddha judge has it
in spades I mean it's a pretty
impressive so people who judge goes even
further it's not just that he like many
other Democrats wants to ban all the
things he wants to blame you you're part
of the problem you see you I mean
literally you hear is people who judge
on CNN who is now going to lecture you
on all the things that you do wrong
because you are an imperfect human being
and thus must be blamed for all of the
problems on earth right now we're in a
mode where we're I think we're thinking
about it mostly through the perspective
of guilt you know from using a straw to
eating a burger am i part of the problem
and in a certain way yes but the most
exciting thing is that we can all be
part of the solution in in a certain way
yes in a certain way you are part of the
problem but we can all be part of the
solution I'm offering you a path to
repentance just follow my political
agenda so you see you're a sinner
repentance comes in the form of voting
for me right it's like old school talk
about Catholic indulgences rightly you
sin and now you must pay this indulgence
to the church and then everything will
be fine
and this is how the Democrats say that
you vote for higher taxes and you have
partaken of the indulgences you
acknowledge your white privilege of
partaking of the indulgences and Buddha
judge does this over and over and over
again
so here's Peabody judge talking about
Christians right so it's not just that
you are part of the problem if you eat
hamburgers or you use straws also people
judge is going
lecture you about religions when I say
that Democrats have become the religious
fundamentalists Peabody jej is speaking
the language of religious fundamentalism
he's just doing it from left right here
for as long as there has been faith and
as long as there has been politics there
have been different understandings on
the right thing to do and how these
things fit together but for the the
party and the movement known for beating
other people on the head with their
faith or their interpretation of their
faith it makes no sense to will
literally vote to take food away from
the hungry to essentially be practicing
the very thing that not just a Christian
scriptural tradition but so many others
tell us we're not supposed to do in
terms of harming other people and I do
think there's going to be a reckoning
over that as it turns out it's not mayor
Pete it's pastor Pete there will be a
reckoning God's wrath will descend on
you if you don't vote for people to
judge and his policies you must feel
ashamed you must be scolded
unless you think I'm exaggerating this
listen to people to judge talk about
global warming he's talking about this
use on I guess late night TV and he was
talking about this specifically in the
context of religion again in the same
way that you might hear your preacher
talk about God being unhappy with the
United States on abortion but he says
it's about global warming so you're
gonna have to explain to me the
distinction environmental stewardship
isn't just about taking care of the
planet it's taking care of our neighbor
we were supposed to love our neighbor as
ourselves and the biggest problem we've
climate change isn't just as gonna hurt
the planet I mean in some way shape or
form the plant is still going to be here
it's that we are hurting people people
who are alive right now and people who
will be born in the future the way I see
it I don't imagine that God's gonna let
us off the hook for abusing future
generations any more that then you would
be off the hook for harming somebody
right next to you and with climate
change we're doing both know pastor Pete
Wow but but don't worry guys he is whoa
so this is okay right he's allowed to
speak the language of religious
fundamentalism and scold you and make
you feel guilty and try and shame you
into the precepts of his political
religion by invoking God he does it over
and over and over again he did it again
last night he talked about the Bible
welcomes the stranger he's if any
I can invoke the Bible as much on the
campaign trail as pastor Pete does then
they would rightly be seen as as a
religious fanatic trying to invoke God
and the Bible on a routine basis in
order to push their policies
pee poo to judge does it unless like oh
why because the left has its own
religion it's usually in the form of
secular politics what's fun for them and
sort of pranky for them is the fact that
people who judge is trying to take God
in the Bible and then use it against the
very people who typically cite God and
biblical values as the basis for their
own root values so it the left seems to
see pastor Pete is some sort of a a mole
inside the religious camp but the truth
is that he's more patrol but that
troller II is not in fact funny and it's
not interesting and it is part of a
broader left-wing viewpoint which is
that everybody has to be shamed into
doing what you want and they should be
shamed by the forces of of corporate of
corporate homogeneity they should be
forced to do what you want by the force
of government if that can be achieved
here's pastor Pete again in citing the
Bible as we see some of these figures on
the religious right embrace behavior and
I think policies but definitely behavior
that flies in the face not just of my
values but of their own then it reminds
me of all of the parts of scripture
where there's a lot about hypocrisy and
I think we have an obligation to call
that out and to speak about how you know
not just the the Christian faith
tradition that I belong to but pretty
much any religious or non-religious
moral tradition I've ever heard of tells
us that it's really important how we
treat the least among us the most
vulnerable the marginalized that we are
obliged to serve the poor and heal the
sick and clothe the naked and welcome
the stranger stranger by the way being
another word for immigrant and your bad
Christian so there's a Pete Mayor Pete's
pitch as the sort of Ed of the
Democratic Party now which is amazing is
that the is that you are a bad Christian
if you disagree with him that you have
sinned
if you eat hamburgers or use straws this
is the new religion that you will face a
reckoning if you don't agree with him on
global warming and that if you disagree
with him on immigration it's because you
have offended God as represented by
pastor Pete or Pope Pete it's it's
pretty impressive stuff as I say there's
an easy
indulgence that you can they can receive
from pastor Pete and that is simply to
support the Democratic Party agenda and
you see this over and over among actual
top-notch Democrats what they will do is
they say well I've paid my indulgences
don't you see I vote Democrat I support
carbon taxes that will never be
implemented I support bans on various
things that will never be banned I
support all these things that will never
that is my indulgence I'm not gonna do
it myself I'm not actually gonna
undertake doing any of these things
myself instead I'm going to mouth'
support for these broader principles
that buy me off the the favor of people
like pastor Pete as we'll see in just
one second this runs very high in the
ranks of the Democratic Party from
Bernie Sanders talking about how he's
not gonna stop lying to Bill DeBlasio
who continues to take an SUV to his gym
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk about that
cellphone plan so let's be real about
this you're spending too much on your
cell phone coverage like a lot too much
on your cell phone coverage
why well you probably bought that
unlimited data package do you really use
unlimited data on your phone or are you
paying for unlimited data and then just
using a fraction of it and paying way
too much money you don't have to do that
anymore you need mint mobile mint mobile
provides the same premium network
coverage you're used to but at a
fraction of the cost
mint mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down in just 15 bucks a
month every plan comes the limited
nationwide talk and text with mint
mobile you can stop paying for unlimited
data you'll never use choose between
plans with 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
you can ditch your old wireless bill and
start saving with mint mobile right now
mint mobile makes everything incredibly
easy for you they'll transfer your
number over and you keep the same phone
number and all the whole deal to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month which will save you a bundle and
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mint mobile comm slash Ben
that's em int mo bi le mint mobile comm
slash been cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month
mint mobile comm slash been use that
slash been so let them know we sent you
an to get that special deal mint mobile
comm slash Ben okay so again the
beautiful thing about being a Democrat
is that to partake in the religion does
not require that you actually abide by
its dictates you just have to mouth
support for its dictates and that's how
you end up with Tucker Carlson asking
Bill DeBlasio if you're so worried about
climate change why are you taking us UV
to the gym and de Blasio has no answer
how can you take
an SUV to the gym and back every day and
say that you're really worried about
sorry it's a it's a chrysler pacifica
for years it's a Pacifica it's a hybrid
electric it's not an SUV first of all
but it's look I can't imagine in it I
come from a neighborhood I go back to my
neighborhood all the time it's the way
to me then I stay connected to people
that I am able to have a routine that
allows me to be 24/7 the best mayor I
can be but should the climate have to
pay the cost for the lawn it's a few
miles come on
and kentucker here's the great part
about all what do you mean about climate
change oh come on and by the way Bernie
Sanders does the same exact thing is de
Blasio right the oh come on routine but
it's okay for the left because bill de
blasio cares don't you see he cares and
it's the caring that matters it's the
lecturing that matters it's being part
of the wolf skull brigade so you're
either going to be the target of the
wolks cold brigade or you're gonna be
part of the wolf skull brigade you're
either with us or you're against us and
that's gonna become a very unpopular
agenda I can already see it among young
people I think there are a lot of
generations ears we're looking around
and going this is not a world I wish to
occupy where I am seen as either a part
of the wokes cold brigade and the and
Wilkes code religious fervor or I am
their target and you're starting to see
this have blowback it's having blowback
in the world of comedy with Dave
Chappelle and people like Aziz Ansari
it's having blowback in Hollywood
there's a fascinating piece in The New
York Times today called why I quit the
writers room by a guy named Walter
Mosley I never heard of Walter Mosley it
turns out that Walter Mosley is a
novelist screenwriter an executive
producer and writer on FX his snowfall
and the often most recently of elements
of fiction he has a piece today all
about him quitting a writers room
because the corporate woke scolds have
now decided they're gonna cram down the
religious rules of the woke scold left
because here's how the system works a
bunch of old scolds get together and
they decide that they're going to out
people and hurt people and damage
people's careers and damaged
corporations based on bad old tweets you
have sinned and you must repent and the
corporation's cave because the
corporations are risk-averse and so they
actually take he woke schooled agenda
and then they enshrine it in corporate
bylaws they enshrine
in their HR practices and then it turns
out that there's no flexibility in those
practices so when somebody who's a
member of the left sins against the
hierarchy that the left itself is
created they must pay and this is
exactly what happened to Walter Mosley
he says earlier this year I just
finished with the snowfall writers room
for the season when I took a similar job
on a different show it is different
Network I've been in the new room for a
few weeks when I got a call from Human
Resources a pleasant sounding young man
said Mr Mosely it has been reported that
you used the n-word in the writers room
I replied I am the n-word in the writers
room is a black guy he said I he said
very nicely then I could not use that
word except in a script I could write it
but I could not say it me a man whose
people in America have been among other
things slandered by many words but I
could no longer use that particular word
to describe the environs of my
experience I have to stop with the
forward thrust of this story to say that
I had indeed said the word in the room I
hadn't called anyone hadn't called
anyone it I just told the story about a
cop who explained to me on the streets
of LA that he stopped all n-words in
pattie neighborhoods and all paddies in
n-word neighborhoods because they were
usually up to no good I was telling a
true story as I remembered it someone in
the room I have no idea who called HR
and said that my use of the word made
them uncomfortable and the HR rep called
to inform me that such language was
unacceptable to my employers I couldn't
use that word in common parlance even to
an express and experience I lived
through there I was a black man in
America who shares with millions of
others the history of racism and more
often than not treated as subhuman if
addressed at all that history had to be
rendered in words that my employers
regarded as acceptable there I was being
chastised for criticizing the word that
oppressed me in mind for centuries as
far as I know the word is in the
dictionary as far as I know the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights
assure me of both the freedom of speech
and the pursuit of happiness okay he is
right and you can see the political
awakening beginning the Democratic Party
is trying to formalize the rules of
political correctness implement them
from above in both governmental and
corporate terms and people are beginning
to buck against that system you wonder
why the Democrats aren't able to pull
ahead of a very unpopular president like
President Trump this would be the reason
this would be the reason they've set up
a standard that is unlivable even for
folks on the Left I'll give you another
example of this in just one second from
the University of Alabama first let's
talk about September September
it happens to be is national life
insurance Awareness Month you probably
weren't aware of that well now you are
because I just raised your awareness of
national life insurance awareness mom
well now that you're wearing you do
something about it and stop wasting time
you just go be an adult okay if you
should plotz tomorrow you want to make
sure that your family is taken care of
and this is where life insurance comes
in but 40% of Americans don't actually
have life insurance why well because
it's a pain in the butt you don't know
where to buy it you don't know if you
getting the best plan policy genius now
makes it easier than ever to get you
covered policy genius is the easy way to
shop for life insurance online in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape and policy genius doesn't just make
life insurance easy they can also help
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance policy
genius makes it super simple to get life
insurance so you don't have any more
excuses and now that you're aware of
there being national life insurance
Awareness Month we've made you aware go
do the responsible thing and be a
responsible human go to policy genius
calm right now get quotes apply in
minutes make sure you are not buried in
a pauper's grave and leave your family
panelist you can do the whole thing on
your phone like right this very instant
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance go check them out
right now at policy genius com okay
another example of the wolks cold left
standard coming back to bite them
directly in the ass so there's this guy
named Jamie Riley he's the University of
Alabama assistant vice president and
Dean of Students he has now resigned his
position on Thursday after less than
seven months on the job why while
Breitbart news published an article
detailing images of past tweets from
Riley in which he criticized the
American flag and made a connection
between police and racism according to
Jackson Fuentes the press secretary for
the University of Alabama Student
Government Association they confirmed
that Riley is no longer working at the
university Clinton said for us right now
basically all I can tell you is that the
university in dr. Riley have mutually
agreed to part ways so yeah that's true
and we do wish him the best
apparently he resigned his position so
what exactly did this professor actually
tweet out he tweeted out back in 2017
September of 2017 the American flag
represents a systemic history of racism
for my people police are a part of that
system is it that hard to see the
correlation and then he also tweeted I'm
baffled about how the first thing white
people say is that's not racist when
they can't even experience racism you
have zero opinion hashtag
me with your privilege and then he also
sends a tweet saying our movies about
slavery truly about educating the
unaware or to remind black people of our
place in society okay these are all
radical tweets or I mean these are
things that I disagree with I think they
are morally wrong should he lose his job
as assistant vice president and Dean of
Students because he has some old tweets
that I find offensive I think the answer
is no but the world the left has created
is a world without forgiveness and if
the right decides to apply those same
rules to people on the left well then
this is the world the left has created
and I think more and more people are
tired of these rules and more and more
people believe that these rules are
terrible that they're bad for America
that they're bad for the country that
the woke scolding of the left is
tiresome and annoying and that Trump was
the middle finger to that so if this
becomes a battle between pastor Pete and
his and his school marm ish lecturing of
you about your own personal morality and
Donald Trump and is freewheeling on say
anything I don't really care the
American people are not up for more past
repeating they're not they're not up for
more shaming and guilting not about
things that they don't deserve to be
shamed or guilted over like believing in
basic biblical precepts or disagreeing
with Mayor Pete over immigration policy
or wanting to see an actual plan for
climate change that doesn't involve
destroying the United States economy
while China sails along on the shoals of
carbon emissions and so I think that
this is why the Democrats are having
trouble with popularity now again it's
like this election is 2020 election is a
game of hold my beer and it's meme
online where it's like somebody's doing
something stupid you're like well that
that other person couldn't do something
as stupid as that and the other person's
like well hold my beer that's what's
going on right now so Trump is
constantly saying tweeting things that
damaged himself and then the Democrats
are like hold my beer let's do a 7-hour
climate change extravaganza where we
talk about banning cows and air travel
and then Trump is like wait no you hug
my bear and then he's like you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do like a
four-day controversy over whether I was
originally right to have suggested that
hurricane Tory and might make landfall
in Alabama they're like wait what what
why is that a good idea is that
something we really have to do and the
answer according to Trump is yes because
never back down never compromise never
suggest that you could possibly have
gotten nothing wrong like why couldn't
Trump have just said listen got it wrong
I was given
information that durian might make
landfall in Alabama I tweeted that out
at the time it turns out it was wrong
listen to the National Weather Service
look how easy that was
we solved the crisis in 15 seconds but
President Trump saying uh not gonna do
that not interested so he is now tweeted
about hurricane durian repeatedly
repeatedly right because he is trying to
suggest that he was always right when he
was talking about the projected path of
Hurricane durian this became a big
controversy because there was a because
President Trump did a press conference
on September 4th hoping up a map of
Hurricane durian and it showed its
projected storm path or possible storm
path hitting Florida and he had tweeted
out that it might hit Alabama too
so what did he do I mean the supposition
is that President Trump personally took
a sharpie he loved sharpies he took a
sharpie and he actually drew a larger
storm path perfect storm on the map now
to me this is funny because look human
beings are flawed human beings have
foibles President Trump has plenty of
them am I really gonna be like super
offended that this man is very
thin-skinned and arrogant and can't
abide the fact that he made a mistake no
I mean like if you don't know that by
now you haven't been watching closely
enough or you're blind or you're stupid
or whatever but the fact is that Trump
taking a sharpie and going look that's
gonna hit Alabama change the map boom
sharpie fixed it's a little funny isn't
it the media decided to make this in
all-out war how could Trump alter the
hurricane map he's violated federal law
impeach say oh my god so he's Liz so now
they're just throwing the beer back and
forth they're both covered in beer it's
like that scene in the beginning of
Zoolander where everybody's shooting
each other with gasoline and then
somebody we're just waiting for somebody
to light the match at this point we're
having a big gas fight and then we're
just gonna light a match and everybody's
gonna explode because it Trump's like
yeah I'm held maybe and Democrats like
yeah oh they're here now they're all
covered in beer everybody's covered in
beer hey well this is so it's all so
stupid and yet hilarious we'll talk
about it in just one second first let's
talk about sleep quiet as you know I
talk about sleep quality a lot on the
show because I am NOT a good sleeper I'm
good at some things I am bad at other
things one of the things I am
particularly bad at is sleep well one of
the things that makes my sleep ossible
is my Boleyn branch eats everything
Poland branch makes from
to blankets is made from pure 100%
organic cotton you know you don't know
that he's been sleeping in bad sheets
all your life until you try Bowen
branches which are actually excellent
they're so good
that once I got Bowen branch sheets in
my home I actually threw out all my
other sheets because it ruined all the
other sheets for me I realized I was
basically sleeping on a tarp and then
you get bolin branches like oh my god
this is what this is what sheets should
feel like they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store bolin brand sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks that's not
expensive for luxury sheets and also
you're sleeping on them simply every
night shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights there is no risk no reason
not to give them a try try Bullen brand
sheets today you will indeed love them I
know I do to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch com
promo code Ben go to bull and branch
calm today you got 50 bucks off that
first set of sheets that is bull and
branch comp remote code Ben Bo LL and
branch calm promo code Ben alrighty well
we're going to add two more of President
Trump and hurricane durian and then a
fascinating new study that talks about
the economics of marriage and how those
have shifted over time we get to all of
that in just a moment first you have to
go to daily where calm and subscribe why
should you do this thing well not only
with the annual subscriptions you get
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels for $99 a year also get early
access to our Sunday special our Sunday
special this week features Bryan Keating
is a professor over at University of
California San Diego in cosmology we
discuss everything from the Big Bang to
multiple universe theory it really is I
think fascinating in trial of the Sunday
I love doing the Sunday special I get to
talk to interesting people I think some
of the conversations and there are just
top-notch this one I think is really
fascinating for folks who like science
are interested in religion and the
beginnings of the universe here's a
little sample when you talk about you
know is something science does it follow
the centuries-old scientific method
which actually traces back to my
intellectual hero Galileo now Galileo
made some huge whoppers I mean he
believed that you know certain crazy
things about about the universe that we
now know are false and it's too bad
because he could have had a good career
[Laughter]
you ain't got to cancel all the
scientists now that that's the new thing
by the way there was this big story did
you see that story about Rachel Maddow
apparently walking into some sort of
symposium where scientists were being
awarded and she said what's up with the
dude wall and they actually took down
the pictures of the sciences because
Rachel Maddow complained the too many
men were being good at science I think
that we may be done as a country okay
well you should go subscribe there's all
sorts of good stuff happening over it's
daily where to come there will be more
very good stuff in the future like we're
relaunching the website that's a thing
that is happening there will be more
benefits for subscribers behind the
paywall more contact with me if that's a
thing that you desperately want there's
all sorts of good stuff also you help
protect us against the nastiness of the
left which as we say is seeking to
destroy all in its path you protect
shows that you love when you subscribe
so please join the team over at daily
we're calm
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say President Trump all he
should be doing is the Donald Sutherland
at the end of invasion of the body
snatchers face you should just be
screaming and pointing at Democrats
instead we get a week-long news cycle
because he won't let go of the fact that
he was not correct about the path of a
hurricane that has already made landfall
it turned the other way dude
but Trump won't let go of it he's like
just as I said Alabama was originally
projected to behead the fake news didn't
eyes it no what they're saying is that
you were informed that the hurricane was
going to move and then you put with a
sharpie more of the hurricane going in
the wrong direction and then maintained
that so a couple things can be true one
the media are wildly over blowing this I
mean literally members of the media are
like it's it's impeachable doesn't this
show how terrible he is I mean it's a
crisis it's a crisis he took a sharpie
and you put it on a map and it's a
crisis it's not a crisis here's chris
cuomo the dummer of the quote of the
cuomo brothers we're not allowed to call
him Fredo because that's the F word okay
but Chris Cuomo he says that President
Trump he doesn't care about people dying
in hurricanes he only cares about
defending his silly claim about where
the hurricane is going yeah you're right
I'm sure that FEMA has has suspended all
resource allocation because Trump is
using a sharpie you are literally in the
middle of a hurricane and this president
is all about defending himself and his
erroneous claim fake maps compelling
people to justify his claims and not
really focusing on the people who should
be getting help which is what a leader
does oh he's just fighting back against
what the truth even if he were right and
he was wrong you really think this was
the time and this is the way for a
president to act okay I mean are we
really gonna go down this path with the
I love when the meter like he's so
unpresidential it's unprecedent yeah we
know we know man I don't have to tell
you hey welcome to reality where Donald
Trump is president were you unaware that
he's a man named Donald Trump who is
also Donald Trump are we supposed to be
surprised by this two things can be
simultaneously true one this is
particularly stupid to the media making
a big deal out of Donald Trump being
Donald Trump is extraordinarily tiresome
because it's like me being surprised
when my son fusses in the morning when
put on his shoes yeah it's really
irritating also he does it every morning
cuz he's three like if Donald Trump
tweets random crap
have we not adjusted to the fact that
the President of the United States is a
man who tweets random crap pretty sure
we're all aware of us Trump of course
keeps doubling down he says this was the
originally projected path of the
hurricane in the early stages as you can
see almost all models predicted it to go
through Florida and also hitting Georgia
and Alabama I accept the fake news
apologies but was that all no that was
not all there are nine tweets on this
Alabama was going to be hit or grazed
and then hurricane Dorian took a
different path up along the East Coast
the fake news knows this very well
that's why they're the fake news but
wait he's not done in the early days of
the hurricane when it was predicted that
Dorian would go through Miami or West
Palm Beach
even before it reached the Bahamas
certain models strongly suggested that
Alabama and Georgia would be hit as it
made its way through Florida and to the
Gulf instead it turned north and went up
the coast where it continues now in the
one Meredith in Florida the great state
of Alabama would have been hit or grazed
in the path it took no read my full FEMA
statement what I said was accurate I'll
fake news in order to demean okay like
again is this a grant allocation to
things can be true one what Trump is
saying about the original storm path
warnings and all that there's some truth
to that too is this work the allocation
of resources three are the media really
going crazy over Trump being Trump like
Trump is Trump we're all aware we're all
very much aware of the Trump being Trump
is this a smart thing to do however no
it is not a smart thing to do and so I
guess this game of hold my beer will
continue until the end of time or until
2020 election whichever comes first
okay meanwhile there's a fascinating new
study that I want to talk about today
it's really a really interesting new
study from researchers at Cornell
University
they say marriage rates have steadily
declined over the past few decades now
researchers from Cornell University are
offering up a possible explanation there
just aren't as many economically
attractive men for unmarried women to
meet as there used to be previous
studies had attempted to answer why
marriage rates are on the decline but
most focused solely on gender ratio
discrepancies as opposed to looking into
the specific socio-economic
characteristics that make a particular
man and woman a good match according to
study finds org first the study's
authors examined data collected on
recently
between 2007 and 2012 and 2013 and 2017
these data were gathered as part of the
American community surveys cumulative
five year marriage statistics that data
was used to estimate the financial and
socio demographic characteristics of
unmarried women's potential husbands by
creating economic profiles that
resembled real husbands who had married
comparable limits in other words they
would take a two women one was single
one was married they would say the
married woman tends to be married to
this type of dude are there a lot of
that type of dude in the population for
the single woman to be married to and
the answer was no research researchers
found that the estimated potential dream
husbands had an average income about 58%
higher than the actual unmarried men
currently available to unmarried women
the synthetic husbands were also 30%
more likely to be employed than real
single men and 19% more likely to have a
college degree it was also observed that
many racial and ethnic minorities
specifically African American women seem
to be dealing with especially known low
numbers of economically attractive
potential mates so this is sort of
Tucker Carlson's case where I talk about
Carlson has been making the case that
men have been underserved in the labor
force that with the advent of women
moving into the labor force at heavier
and heavier rates there's more
competition for increasing jobs but the
number of jobs is not increasing fast
enough and that that increasing
competition has left a lot of men out of
jobs or in part-time jobs or in lower
earning jobs because of wage competition
and this has led to a decline in
marriage because women want to marry men
who earn more than they do or at least
as much as they do they want to marry
men who are better educated everybody
sort of wants to marry up is basically
the the supposition and this study is
supposed to show exactly that and this
study is basically saying they're not
enough men who are earning high salaries
for women to marry okay so that's a
piece of data I think there's some flaws
with the study I think first of all
correlation does not equal causation it
is quite possible that women are
marrying the choicest men specifically
because they are the choicest men but
that doesn't explain why low-income
women are unable to find men who are
earning slightly more than that there
are plenty of middle-class men who are
unmarried and a lot of low in you would
imagine that what you would see if that
were the case if it were really just
about the number of women not matching
up with the number of men who earn more
well you would expect to see as a is a
decline in the levels of marriage as
female income went up right you'd expect
to see a lot
poor women getting married because there
are a lot of people who are richer than
poor in the United States a lot of men
and then as you moved up the income
scale you would expect to see women who
earn a lot of money
marrying less and less and that's
actually the opposite of what you see
right what you actually see is that
women who are better educated tend to
get married more often right it's
actually it's kind of fascinating as you
increase the income scale what you see
is that higher levels of education
actually correlate highly with higher
levels of marriage so this kind of cuts
against the the normal the normal
supposition which is that women who will
go to college are women's empowerment
specialists and they never get married
actually not true actually not true as
people get more educated they actually
tend to live more conservatively which
is kind of fascinating they tend to vote
more liberal and then live more
conservatively which is very interesting
according to a Pew Research study from
2017 half of US adults today are married
sure that has remained relatively stable
in recent years but it's now nine
percentage points over the past quarter
century and dramatically different from
the peak of 72 percent in 1960 the
decline in the share of married adults
can be explained in part by the fact
that Americans are marrying later in
life but delayed marriage may not
explain all of the drop off the share of
Americans who have never married has
been rising steadily in recent decades
marriage rates are now more closely
linked to socioeconomic status than ever
before and what the Census Bureau's a to
show is that the education gap in
marital status has continued to widen
percentage of US adults 25 and older
married by education sixty-five percent
of people with a bachelor's plus degree
are married in the United States age 25
and older high school or less only 50
percent of Americans are married by the
over the age of 25 only half that's a
very significant difference so is that
about the lack of marriage about
partners it seems probably not because
the fact is again most Americans are not
poor so if you are poorly educated or
you have lower levels of education there
should be more marriage about partners
available to you because you're here in
education most Americans are here in
education that's it that's a much
broader gamut of people who you could
choose to marry presumably so the data
don't quite match up the economic
hollowing out theory doesn't quite match
up now it is true that higher earning
men would provide more of an
benefit for marriage obviously but what
this really goes to is a cultural effect
but this really goes to so this is this
has been the big battle inside the
conservative movement right now over the
role of government so people like Tucker
have suggested that what you need is
government intervention ISM to shore up
male wages in order so that people will
get married and there is some truth to
the idea that as male wages have
relatively declined compared to female
wages that the marriage rates have gone
down but it is also true that exactly
what you would expect to happen with
regard to economics his has been
exacerbated wildly wildly by these a
Cline of religion in America and what
you are expecting what again what you
would expect to see is that people who
are lower on the income totem pole
should be getting married more often if
they are simply seeking a partner who
earns more than they do because again
they're low on the income totem pole and
instead what you are seeing is that high
school educated males are not getting
married as much that the middle income
and lowering and blue-collar workers are
not getting married as much which is
quite fascinating that the real problem
is existing lower down on the income
spectrum so there's an article in the
Atlantic today talking about America
without family got our patriotism
because there was a new poll we talked
about on the show showing that younger
people in America do not believe in
family god or patriotism and where is
that population really located the
author of this piece in the Atlantic
Tara Thompson a staff writer he points
out that disproportionately
disproportionately it's not really about
youth alone it's about something bigger
he says there's this blanket distrust of
institutions of authority but it's not
confined to the the relatively young and
it isn't confined to the over educated
he points out a study from Catherine
Eden and Timothy Nelson at Princeton
University and return and Johns Hopkins
and Robert Francis at Whitworth they
published a paper based on lengthy
interviews conducted from 2000 to 2013
with older low-income men without a
college degree in black and white
working-class neighborhoods in the
Boston Charleston Chicago and
Philadelphia
areas now what you would expect that
these are people who want to get married
but can't get married cuz they're not
earning enough right that would be the
theory behind sort of what Tucker says
and what this new study says about the
economics of marriage it turns out a lot
of these dudes just don't want to get
married
according to
this particular study many of these men
having been disconnected from the stable
unionized pension paying jobs of their
fathers reject the disease state of
American institutions in ways that
Millennials might find relatable first
low-income working-class men are turning
away from organized religion even faster
than Millennials and Gen Z and this I
think is the causative factor since the
1970s church attendance among white men
without a college degree has fallen even
more than among white college graduates
according to the paper they remain
deeply spiritual without being
traditionally devout they avoid Church
instead they prefer to browse the
internet and libraries from makeshift
pieces of religious self they've
detached from religious institutions and
many poor working-class men now reject
the nuclear family itself their marriage
rates have declined in lockstep with
their church attendance right not in
lockstep with their economic situation
in in lockstep with their church
attendance the authors note a number of
these men were eager to have close
relationships with their kids even when
they have little relationship with
mothers many of them had given up on
romance with the relationship with with
women and they're facing challenges with
regard to mental health specifically
because they've abandoned a lot of these
institutions and this is actually what
you see the share of married adults
varies widely by religious practice and
here the correlation is extraordinarily
high right the more religious you are
the more likely you are to be married in
the United States it's not that the
richer you are the more likely you are
to be married anymore religious you are
the more likely you are to be married
well religion crosses all sorts of
income lines so it really doesn't look
like a wealth effect so much as it is an
institutional effect because here's the
deal there are two reasons to get
married
the reason number one is because is in
economic it's an economic decision
they're the the changes in American
economics obviously we have an impact so
if you're getting married because you
believe the two incomes are better than
one or because you are looking for a
breadwinner in your home and you can't
find a breadwinner in your home
obviously that's going to impact
marriage rates but the fact is most
people historically in the United States
and abroad do not get married for the
economic arrangement they don't most
people traditionally have gotten married
because they believe that it is a it is
the right thing to do that it betters
you that you are fulfilling a religious
obligation and that and and that is
particularly important in industrialized
countries because it used to be right in
poorer countries
that the economics and the religion wind
up the economics and the religion lined
up really well in fact because you
wanted that you were poor your biggest
asset was going to be your children
right your children are gonna take care
of you in your old age they're gonna
help you work the fields they're gonna
make sure that you were taken care of
they were going to join the family
business so you wanted to pop out little
workers right I mean found on an
economic level you're going to create
your own labor supply and the only way
to do that is to marry mom and then have
kids and so that lined up perfectly with
the dictates of your religion which also
suggested you were fulfilling a
spiritual and religious duty to get
married and have kids
well now what you've seen in the West is
a bifurcation of the economics in the
religion so religions has the same thing
that it always said which is it is
spiritually fulfilling it is a godly
mandate for you to get married and pop
out kids that this is something that you
ought to do will make you better it is
you fulfilling a spiritual requirement
of you dictated by God religion has not
changed one iota on this which is why
people who are deeply believe in
religion are still getting married but
the economics have changed because now
having kids is a net cost in fact women
who have kids that is a according to
Elizabeth Warren that is one of the
single best predictors of a woman going
bankrupt is having children so kids are
actually a net cost right you because
now the government's gonna take care of
you in your old age now we have a social
welfare net your kids are not a labor
supply you have to pay for your kids
education all the way through college
and sometimes grad school so the
economics are diverging from the
religious mandate so the question is
which is more likely to fix America or
both one to quote unquote fix the
economics that's very difficult without
either changing the labor the labor
system in the United States through
subsidies or through regulations which
would lower the average level of the
American consumption habits tremendously
it would miss allocate resources who
would not be an economic language
purrito efficient they do it would
damage some people at the expense of
other people is that the best path do
you really think that we can
re-establish an economic system where it
is economically beneficial for women to
marry and men to marry and them to have
kids because that that has never applied
in industrialized countries which is why
as people get richer they didn't have
your children right because kids cost
and instead of being a benefit or should
we be encouraging people to reconnect
with a lot of the religious and
spiritual institutions that used to give
people meaning because it turns out that
the lack of meaning is probably a better
predictor of whether you're going to
make solid decisions in your personal
life then whether you earn a lot of
money or whether you don't earn a lot of
money the correlation there is really
high the study from from pew shows that
among agnostics and atheists only about
35% are married among people who are
members the Presbyterian Church or the
UCC or the Evangelical Lutheran Church
it is well above 60% and this holds true
for virtually all all churches in the
United States that people attend on a
regular basis so is it a cultural
problem or is it an economic problem you
can blame it on economics but it's a lot
harder to change the basic rules of
economics it is a lot easier I think and
I think frankly more fruitful I think
the rules of economics are always going
to push against you because they just go
for what is most efficient and what is
most efficiently not cut in favor of the
social institutions you love you have to
brick by brick rebuild those social
institutions if you wish to reestablish
the importance of marriage okay time for
a quick thing that I like so here is a
thing that I like I do I'm always amused
by the Dennis Prager my friend Dennis
Prager he has this very simple thought
experiment that he likes to do and his
thought experiment is you're standing
above a river there's a drowning person
and there's your dog which one do you
save and he's always surprised that a
huge number of people say that they
would save the dog
I am similarly surprised but that same
logic is now applied to the logic of
abortion we'll win over a preggers you
did a video in which he went around
asking a bunch of liberals whether we
should protect the lives he'll unborn
Eagles unborn Eagles eggs and then he
asked them about unborn humans watch
what's up guys this is will wit with
Prager you today we're in Echo Park
where we have a petition to stop the
killing of Eagles stop the destruction
of eagle eggs but then we're asking them
to sign a petition to stop the killing
of babies yeah double signatures fine
like three white claws today and so I
didn't know if you guys would want to
thank you thank you so much when we
actually mean to talk to you real quick
we have one other petition about
stopping the killing of humans too
stop the killing of babies babies right
like you hate it you made abortion we
want to protect their rights too even
though being like unborn so no if you
want to
I fully support abortion why do you
support not the killing of unborn Eagles
but the killing of unborn children I
think it's the mother's decision
the babies are gross see babies are
gross yes well this is like you know
what it does to your body you're not a
woman so you'd have no idea a human
woman should have more rights probably
than a bald eagle yeah okay abortion
Thanks Wow Wow
yep there there's some real
philosophical disconnect right there
okay one other thing that I like so drew
brees the woke police came for Drew
Brees today that the quarterback of the
New Orleans Saints he had cut a video
for Focus on the Family for national
bring a Bible to school day
drew Brees a religious Christian and he
had just got this video saying that you
should bring a Bible to school to
demonstrate your religious fealty that
doesn't violate the First Amendment it
doesn't ruin your school or anything and
that's fine but wokes colts came after
him because they were like well he
worked with Focus on the Family and
focus on the family is in favor of
traditional marriage and that means
they're evil so Drew Brees is evil well
drew Brees was asked about this and he's
like are you guys effing kidding me I
cut a video on behalf of people being
able to bring Bibles to school and now
I'm on the chopping block here's drew
brees defending himself as well he
should there's been a lot of negativity
spread about me in the LGBTQ community
recently based upon a article that
someone wrote with a very negative
headline that I think led people to
believe that somehow I was aligned with
an organization that was anti LGBTQ what
I did was I filmed a video recently that
was encouraging kids to bring their
Bibles to school for national bring your
Bible to school day it was as simple as
that so I'm not sure why the negativity
spread or why people try to rope me into
certain negativity I do not support any
groups that discriminate or that have
their own agendas that are trying to
promote inequality okay so you know
again good for drew brees the woke
police will come for anybody man and
then you cannot give an inch you can I
give an inch because they're just the
worst already we don't have time for
things that I hate because basically the
whole show this week has been about
things that I hate so we will be here a
little bit later with two additional
hours of content or alternatively we'll
see you here next week I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you